CHRISTINE BREINER: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video, I'd
like us to work
on the following problem that
has to do with tangent planes
and approximations.
So we know that a rectangle--
we'll say a rectangle
has sides x and y, and
we know that to find
the area of the rectangle
then, we just take x times y,
and I would like us to
approximate the area for x
equal to 2.1 and y equal to 2.8.
And obviously, with
this type of equation,
it's not hard to
just compute this,
but I'd like us to use the
tangent plane approximation
to determine the
value, and then we'll
compare it to the actual
value, just to give us
an idea of how we can
use the tangent plane
to approximate things.
And obviously, I'd like to
do this near x equal 2 and y
equal 3.
So when you're doing your
tangent plane approximation,
do the approximation at
x equal 2 and y equal 3.
And then when you're
done with that,
I would like you to
answer this question.
So near x equal 2 and y equal
3, which has the greater effect?
A change in x or an
equal change in y?
So if I change by
x in the same value
as I change by y, which will
have the greater impact?
So why don't you pause the
tape, work on the problems,
and when you're ready to see
how I do them, bring it back up,
and I'll come back and show you.
OK, welcome back.
So we're going to work on this
problem, and as I mentioned,
the first thing we want to
do is do a tangent plane
approximation near x
equal 2 and y equal 3.
So let me write down
what we're going
to need in order to do that.
First, we'll remind ourselves
that in this case, what
I'm going to
approximate is the area
function for a rectangle,
which is A of x,
y is equal to x times y.
So that's the function I'm
going to be approximating.
And now the actual
approximation,
the tangent plane approximation,
has the following form.
So we know A of x,
y is approximately--
well, it's going to be the
area evaluated at the point I'm
interested in, which
we said was 2 comma 3,
right, plus the x-derivative
of area evaluated at 2
comma 3, times the change in x.
And the change in x is where x
is now versus where we started,
which is at x equal 2.
And then the same
thing in terms of y.
So you do the y-derivative
evaluated at 2 comma 3,
and then you do the change in y.
And since we started at y
equals 3, the change in y
is y minus 3, OK?
So now we obviously need to
fill in three quantities here.
The three things we need
to evaluate: area evaluated
at (2, 3), its x-derivative
evaluated at (2, 3),
and its y-derivative
evaluated at (2, 3).
So let me just point
out what we have.
Area evaluated at (2, 3),
well, that's just 2 times 3,
which we can do, so that's 6.
That's pretty easy.
Now A sub x, so the
derivative of the area
function with respect to x.
The derivative of the area
function with respect to x
is just y.
y in that case we
treat as a constant.
We take this derivative.
We just get y back.
And so, A sub x
evaluated at (2, 3)
is going to be y,
which-- y here is 3,
so we get A sub x is
equal to 3 at (2, 3).
In a similar vein, we can
immediately look and see
that A sub y evaluated at
(2, 3) is going to be 2.
And the reason for
that, of course,
is if we look back
here, the derivative
of A with respect to y is x,
so evaluating it at (2, 3)
gives us 2.
OK.
So now we just have
to fill everything in.
So my tangent
plane approximation
now says I get 6 plus 3 times x
minus 2 plus 2 times y minus 3.
And what I wanted was the
area at 2.1 comma 2.8.
So if I fill in those
values for x and y--
so 2.1 is x and 2.8 is
y-- if I fill those in,
I get that this is
equal to-- well, I'll
keep writing
approximately just to be
safe-- is 6 plus 3 times--
well, 2.1 minus 2 gives me a 0.1
there and 2 times 2.8 minus 3
gives me a negative 0.2 there,
so I get a negative 0.4,
I get a positive 0.3,
so together this
is a negative 0.1.
6 minus 0.1 gives me 5.9.
So the area based
on the approximation
is 5.9 square units.
And, in actuality, if
you multiply it out,
I think you get
something like 5.88,
so the approximation
is very good, right?
We're close to
(2, 3) and that is
one of the reasons we can
know it's going to be very,
it should be very good.
It should be pretty good, OK?
Now, I just have to answer the
second part of the question.
So let me remind us what
the second part was.
It was near x equal
2 and y equal 3,
which has a greater effect?
A change in x or an
equal change in y?
And to do that, it's really
easiest to come back and look
at maybe this line.
I'll underline this
line right here.
Actually, I'll box it, OK?
This value will represent
the change in x.
So we started at 2,
and we go somewhere,
and that'll represent
the change in x.
This value represents
the change in y.
So if we look at which has a
greater impact near (2, 3),
if my change in x and my
change in y are equal,
then obviously this term
has a bigger impact,
because there's a 3.
The coefficient here is 3 and
the coefficient here is 2.
And so the point is, changes
in x will have a greater
effect than changes in y.
And what this corresponds
to pictorially
is if we make a slice
where we keep y constant
and we look at the curve in
the xz-plane, that corresponds
to the fact that the derivative
in the xz-plane of the curve
there is more significant--
the curve there
has a steeper derivative-- than
if I kept the x-value fixed
and I looked in the yz-plane
and I looked at the curve there.
So the sort of
one-dimensional picture
is that the derivative of
a curve in the x-direction,
keeping y fixed, is
steeper than the derivative
of the curve in the
y-direction, keeping x fixed.
So maybe-- hopefully,
that wasn't more confusing
than it should have been.
From here, you can
see it right away,
but that's sort of the
picture of it as well.
So I think that's
where I'll stop.